today it is my pleasure to officially
introduce to you archon an open- Source
AI agent that literally builds other AI
agents and I've covered it a bit on my
channel already but I haven't given it a
proper introduction or shared with you
the crazy Big Ideas that I have for it
I'm going to be using it both as a
teaching tool and also to eventually
build it into an absolute monster of an
AI agent that spins up other agents on
demand and I'm doing it all in public
for you to follow along learn from and
contribute to if you want to be a part
of something big and if we do this right
Aron could easily be one of the most
important AI agents out there just hear
me out on this coding is hands down the
biggest and strongest use case for AI
right now and I'm not just trying to get
you on a hype train using AI to code
really does seem to be top of mind for
everyone including every company
building llms just look at the huge
coding Focus for Claude 3.7 Sonet deep
seek R1 quen 2.5 coder and I am all over
this right now because there is a gold
mine of opportunities for us to build AI
apps that use llms to help us write code
cuz here's the thing there are a lot of
generalist AI coders out there like
winds surf cursor and Klein but not a
lot of specialized AI agents that can
get the job done really well for a
specific framework or tackling specific
problems we have some specialized tools
like bolt and lovable for creating
incredible front ends but what about an
AI coding assistant that creates other
AI agents runs them and iterates on them
and we need this because it's becoming
increasingly clear that AI agents will
dominate the landscape of software going
forward and if you can create
specialized agents on demand that tackle
all of your problems well then you my
friend own the world and that is why I'm
building archon you can think of it like
bolt but for agents instead of front
ends and a lot more so let me show you a
demo of it right now and then stick
around because I'll share my crazy
vision for the project as well so archon
can be run in two ways first as a
standalone app with a dedicated
interface that I'll show later but also
and this is what gets me really excited
you can use archon as an engine to build
AI agents within AI idees like I'm
showing wind surf right here you can do
the same with something like cursor and
Klein as well and So within my wind surf
this is using the model context protocol
from Claude I literally have archon as a
tool for wind surf to use you can kind
of think of it as a sub agent when wind
surf realizes it needs that specialized
agent intelligence it'll invoke archon
to generate the code and then that code
will be returned to windsurf and then
implement it straight away in my
development environment it is super neat
and so going over to this interface that
I'll cover more later for archon I have
this service up and running for archon
which is the core of my mCP server and
then I even have an mCP tab here that
shows you for each of these coding
assistants the exact configuration to
put in for mCP and how to do all that as
well so I make it super easy to get up
and running with wind surf cursor and
Klein for archon all right so now let's
give archon a spin in Wind surf I'm just
going to create a very basic agent right
now in more dedicated videos later on
I'll build out more complex use cases
and it just will make more sense as I
build out archon so right here simple AI
agent that uses the brave API to search
the web and we can see right away that
wind surf is getting into using the
archon tools and now it is actually
invoking our agent with this tool call
right here and we'll see in a little bit
that we can watch the logs and in the
archon UI as well when it's making the
request to our mCP server and the thing
that I want to really emphasize here is
that you can use a generalist AI coder
like wind surf like I can go and
reference the pantic AI documentation or
the Lang graph documentation like this
to have wind serf build these agents
with the same Frameworks that archon
uses but because these AI ID are so
generalist it never works as well as I
want want it to and that's why we need
something specialized like archon that
knows how to work with these Frameworks
through instructions that we give it
through better rag retrieval from the
documentation so many opportunities that
we have to implement these
specializations and so right here we got
the result back from archon it told wind
surf the files to create and so now it's
going ahead and creating these all in my
development environment following the
exact structure that I tell archon to
produce where we have this agent right
here that is producing literally perfect
pantic AI code I mean I'm just kind of
glossing over this right here but this
looks perfect and then it generates an
em. example file so it thinks about
things like our environment variables
and the requirements that we have as
well and even generates a readme that
helps us get started with this agent
which is just absolutely beautiful and
we can even go back here and ask it to
iterate on the agent and then archon
will be invoked again to update the code
for the agent and all the updates that
it gives back to wind surf wind surf or
your AI IDE will edit the necessary
files so you don't have to rewrite
anything from scratch and this entire
time within the UI for archon we can see
the logs like these are the logs from
when we used archon just now and then
any future iterations will show up here
in real time as well so it's easy to
track everything happening in the mCP
server as well it's just such a good
combination to use Aron along with an AI
IDE because we don't want to build
another VSS code Fork we want to focus
on creating archon is as this
specialized engine to right now work
with pantic AI and L graph but also I
want to implement in the future
basically every framework that we have
like crew AI llama index and autogen all
of these so that archon can be this AI
agent generator and so super cool stuff
it does take a couple of extra credits
because you have to use the llm calls in
both archon and your AI IDE but if this
can stop a lot of hallucinations and
make it actually generate agents faster
in the end that is going to save you a
lot of credits and that's the most
important thing is we want to be
developing agents correctly and we want
to do it quickly and so right now I'll
show you how to get up and running with
archon and then also I want to show the
crazy ideas that I have to take archon
from its infancy where it is now into
something that truly is an absolute
monster to generate AI agents on Dem man
not only creating the code here but also
iterating autonomously and running these
agents itself that is going to be the
dream so here is the GitHub repository
for arcom which I'll have a link to in
the description of this video and I have
covered already on my channel how I
built archon from scratch so I'll link
to that video right here but essentially
archon uses a combination of my two
favorite Frameworks pantic Ai and Lang
graph for this agentic workflow that can
intelligently build agents much better
than General AI coding assistance and
I'm building archon in iterations for
two reasons first I'm building in public
I want you to be able to contribute and
follow along as I'm building out archon
and then also I'm building an
interations because I'm using this as a
teaching tool to show you how to build
more complex agents with pantic AI and L
graph and so when I have to explain
something more complex like this I want
to break it down into simple steps and
so the iterations of archon are those
simple steps so starting with a simple
agent then implementing Lang graph for a
more powerful agentic flow for agent
creation and then I added in mCP support
in version three and then the most
recent version is where I added in that
huge streamlet interface for you to
manage everything for archon and the
reason that I'm focusing on pantic AI
and L graph specifically is because a
lot of the the other Frameworks out
there like Lane chain for example they
are what's called an abstraction
distraction in my mind they try to
implement so much for you that you lose
a lot of that customizability and
control that you want when you're
building your AI agents but I don't feel
like I lose that with pantic AI and L
graph I do want to integrate other
Frameworks at some point though more on
that later but that's why I'm focusing
on these Frameworks and so yeah there's
just so much that you can read here as
far as the vision and future iterations
of archon I'll get into that more in a
little bit but as far as actually
getting up and running with archon I've
made it as easy as I possibly could so
if you scroll down a little bit in the
read me you'll see the first option to
install with Docker it is just three
commands get up and running so stinking
easy you can install with just python if
you want as well just a couple of more
commands Docker is the preferred way but
either way you'll have that streamlet
interface up and running that'll walk
you through setting up everything for
archon like the environment variables
your agent service for mCP your
documentation for Rag and it'll help you
knock them out one by one super quickly
so it is very easy to get up and running
and I might do a dedicated video later
on where I show how to get archon up and
running from scratch but I hope that
these instructions make it easy enough
to do it for yourself and I know that
people have already been doing that so
once you have archon up and running with
Docker or just pure python the first tab
in the interface is this intro tab
that'll get you started with everything
that you need to have archon up and
running either within the chat interface
that we have right here in the UI or as
an mCP server like I demonstrated
earlier so it walks you through setting
up your environment variables your
database which is using superbase the
documentation crawling which is just
pantic AI right now but I want to use a
lot of other docs later on and then
setting things up for mCP as well and so
each of these tabs I have poured a lot
into making absolutely perfect so you
can set all of your environment
variables right here in the UI for
example so you don't have to do anything
with a andv file and this helps you set
up everything for your database as well
crawling the documentation making sure
you have things set up that you have
your table setup before you crawl the
documentation and create everything for
Rag and then we have the documentation
tab which I won't show this right now
it's super cool how you can click this
button and it'll run that crawl for AI
python script behind the scenes to crawl
the pantic AI documentation and then
update you in real time as it's
processing each page of the docs and
then future sources come as well and
then we have the agent service that I
showed earlier where you can watch the
logs for your mCP server and then the
setup instructions for your different AI
idees like Klein cursor and windsurf
both with Docker so if you set things up
with Docker there's one way you have to
configure it versus the pure python
implementation there's another way and
these uh configurations are Dynamic to
your operating system and the path that
you have to things like the mCP server
script and then we have the last section
right here this is what I want to spend
some time on I created a dedicated
section of this archon interface just to
detail all of the future iterations that
I want to implement because I don't want
to just explain that briefly in the
readme I want to put a huge emphasis on
the big plans that I have for archon so
I have this dedicated page outlining
everything in excruciating detail
because I want to show you the vision
that I have and really hope get you
behind this as well so the first big
thing that I want to knock out next with
archon going into version five is a
multi-agent coding workflow and what I
mean by that I have this graph here that
outlines this nicely I want to take the
primary coding agent that I just showed
you in the agentic workflow and split it
up into sub agents that specialize in
different parts of the code generation
like one to create the prompt another to
define the tools for our agent another
to create the dependencies for things
like dat based connections and API keys
and then one to create the instance of
the agent itself and Define things like
the large language model to use and I
want to do this for two reasons the
first one is there is a huge use case
with agentic workflows to have different
llms tackling different parts of a
problem kind of like what we're seeing
right here and then come together to
aggregate everything into a final result
for the user and again archon is
partially a teaching tool and so this is
a great opportunity for me to
demonstrate this huge use case in a IC
workflows with something practical and
then the other reason I want to do this
is in general just because you can give
a lot of instructions to an llm just
because the system prompt and all the
tools can fit in the context window
doesn't mean you should do it because
llms can get overwhelmed when you give
them too much to do and so splitting our
coder agent into different sub agents
means we have these specialized parts of
the workflow that handle different
things so we should get much better
results and I've implemented these kind
of work Flows In other projects it
definitely does improve the results a
lot so I'm looking forward to version
five a lot and then going into version
six I want to develop a tool library and
example integration so essentially
giving pre-built tools and example
agents to help archon create new agents
better because with the tool Library if
we have something like this I mean this
is a very preliminary look at what the
configuration might look like we have
all these tools that are predefined for
something like web search or querying a
database and so that way when archon
builds the agent it can use a tool that
looks like this that's already defined
in an agent in a very simple way so that
instead of archon having to build that
tool from scratch it can pull it from
the library and inject it right into the
code and so that way we don't have to
worry about hallucinating the creation
of tools when that's a tool that's
already been built a thousand times we
might as well just have that ready to be
pulled in whenever an agent needs
something like a weather tool or the
ability to query a database and it's the
similar kind of idea with example agent
so instead of having to Define this
structure from scratch for an agent it
can look at an example agent like the
weather agent that we see in the pantic
AI documentation so using this as its
grounding Point what does a basic pantic
AI agent look like so we can use this
and then build on top of it for any more
complex use cases that we'd want to make
with pantic AI and then going into
version seven I want to include the Lang
graph documentation within archon's
knowledge base so we have more than just
pantic Ai and this is where we get into
archon being able to work with more and
more Frameworks so as a starting point
adding in Lane graph as well but then I
want to add in crew Ai and llama index
I'll get into this more in another
version but this is a kicking it off
essentially making it so that instead of
it being hardcoded to use pantic AI for
everything we can start to incorporate
other Frameworks allow the user to
choose which framework archon will build
and maybe even have it intelligently
determined and based on the agent that
it's building should it use just pantic
AI or should it use Lang graph and
pantic AI together and then once we have
another Frameworks maybe it chooses to
use one of those instead just depending
on what we are building exactly and so
this is an example of a l graph agent
just showing more complex agentic
workflows that you can't build with only
pantic Ai and so adding in L graph to
the capabilities of archon is just going
to make it be able to build more and
more complex use cases which we need for
the AG agents that we have in the real
world solving these important problems
for us then going into version 8 we get
back to improving the agentic flow for
archon itself with self feedback loops
right now archon when it produces the
Asian code immediately goes to you as
the user to give feedback but what if
you want it to autonomously iterate on
the agent sometimes it knows better than
you what it needs to work on or maybe
the hallucinations are kind of silly and
it's easy enough for the llm to just
correct it itself we want that kind of
power within Arc that's what we're doing
with imersion eight and then going down
into Version 9 here we have self agent
execution this is going to be one of the
more challenging parts of archon but I
cannot wait for this because right now
any AI coding assistant the generalists
like wind Surf and cursor archon if they
build the code for an agent it doesn't
execute in any way there's no way to
automatically hook up a database for reg
or to get another service installed like
CRX for Local web search like you don't
have that functionality and so I want to
build that into archon so once it
creates the code for the agent and maybe
gets the green light from the user that
everything looks good then it would use
the local AI package I've covered this
on my channel a lot to spin up an
isolate an environment with the database
like a vector database a SQL database uh
web search capabilities they'll have
that all packaged together ready for the
AI agent to hook into so we would create
the agent as a container bake it into a
Docker compos stack with all these other
services so it has this environment
ready to execute right away and this
gets into so many more possibilities in
the future as well being able to
automatically test and execute these
agents and really improve that
autonomous iteration so it's more than
just the llm reasoning about the code
that was outputed but it can literally
test the agent and then see any errors
and work on it that way so I just can't
wait for this and then I alluded to this
a lot already but for version 10 I want
to implement multi-f framework support
So pantic AI L graph Lang chain egno
crew Ai and llama index are all the big
ones that I know of and even though
pantic Ai and Lan graph are my favorites
I know that people have different
preferences and there are reasons to use
other ones maybe if you want something
more simple like crew AI for example so
I want archon to support all of that and
then going into version 11 an autonomous
framework learning process so
essentially whenever archon creates a
good Agent or defines good tools and it
iterates and tests and confirms that I
wanted to add that to its examples and
to the tool Library so that it can
continuously give itself better examples
and tools to have this self-improvement
process I think that would just be so
cool maybe even doing things like
adjusting its own system prompt as well
as it iterates over time and realizes
what makes the agents work the best so
very far out there I mean these last few
that we have are definitely more
advanced things but I would love to get
to this point also probably a lot more
versions coming later as well we're up
to version 13 already but yeah there's
so many ways that we could take Aron
much much further even and then going on
to version 12 Advanced rag techniques
cuz right now the methods that I have
for exploring the knowledge base with
regag they work pretty well but I
haven't implemented that many Advanced
Techniques things like hybrid search
reranking uh query decomposition or
better chunking through things like
hierarchical chunking there's a lot of
opportunities that we have here to make
it so that archon can understand and use
the documentation for all our different
Frameworks much better and then the last
version that I have at least for now is
the mCP agent Marketplace so being able
to take these agents that we' built with
archon and publish them to a Marketplace
an mCP Marketplace so that other people
can bring them in as sub agents to use
within their AI Ides or any other mCP
clients so just like archon is a tool a
sub agent that an mCP client can use the
agents itself produces can also be used
as sub agents it gets very meta here
again I don't want to dive into
everything that would be involved with
this but I think this would just be so
cool it just a way for everything that
Arcon creates to be reusable by other
people and shared in something like an
mCP agent Marketplace then for future
Integrations I don't know exactly which
version these will fit into but I want
to integrate with these different
services so starting with Langs Smith
here this is Lang Chain's tracing and
monitoring platform it just gives you a
very good inside scoop with what's
happening with your agentic workflows
it'll help us better debug archon and
the Agents that archon creates so
definitely want to integrate with Lang
Smith at some point also could could use
something like Lang fuse as well so
there's a couple different options here
but since we're working with Lang graph
as one of the core components to archon
I think Lang Smith certainly makes sense
and then also an mCP Marketplace and
this is different than version 13 so
this is for publishing Aron agents to
mCP marketplaces but I'm talking about
actually having archon in mCP
marketplaces so that people can use it
as an mCP server directly through there
so they can run everything without
having to go through my GitHub repo and
get everything set up themselves I think
this would be super cool and then also
other Frameworks besides pantic AI
obviously this is covered in version 10
so this one I know where it' slot in a
couple of these others I'm not sure
exactly which version I'd add them in
but this one is very clearcut here um
and then also other Vector databases
besides superbase a lot of really
popular options that I have listed out
here I think it'd be good because people
appreciate different Vector databases
for different things like quadrant is
faster than superbase you can also
self-host it pine cone runs serverless
it's not open source but it's very very
fast so there's reasons to use different
ones it'd be good to integrate that as
well and then last of all the local AI
package which I want to integrate um
specifically for version 9 when we have
the self- agent execution so I know
where this one slots in as well but this
will just be so cool to tie everything
with archon to the local AI package that
I also have been pouring my heart and
soul into so that is literally
everything as far as future Integrations
and future iterations of archon so many
exciting things planned and yeah if
you're not pumped about this I don't
know what to tell you because I myself
am just so stoked for what archon is now
and what it's going to turn into as I
build it out and as we build it out
together so that is archon and the
awesome plans that I have for it in a
nutshell and I encourage you to be a
part of this journey follow along as I
build it out contribute if you're
interested and just try it out and
suggest features for me and the last
thing that I want to say really quick is
that archon is the perfect example of
what I try to do on my channel I try to
build agents that are complex enough to
be powerful practical and not easily
replaced but also build them in a way
where I can break down these complex
topics into things that are easy to
understand for you so I can teach you
best how to build AI agents so if you
appreciated this content and you're
looking forward to more things archon
and AI agents I would really appreciate
a like and a subscribe and with that I
will see you in the next video